اذا
تسابق الزمن قبل حلول فصل الربيع حيث تخشى
من هجوم الروسي الجديد وصفته سي ان ان
بانه سيكون ربيعا وحشيا القوات الاوكرانيه
تتدرب على بعد كيلو مترات قليله من حدود
بيلاروسيا وتجرى بعض التدريبات في بلده
بلده بريبيات المهجوره منذ كارثه النوويه
عام 1986 هنا في هذه البلده تتدرب القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه على اقتحام المباني
وكيفيه استخدام الشاحنات الصغيره بمدافع
على الشاشه ثقيله وايضا مدافع مضاده
للطائرات كي تواجه اكثر من 100 و50,000
جندي تم تجنيدهم في الخريف الماضي وتم
تدريبهم طبعا ودمجهم في وحدات جاهزه
للمعركه هنا ايضا حسب باسيا الامريكيه
ولاجل ذلك تعمل اوكرانيا بشكل اساسي على
تحويل جميع جيشها القائم على المعدات
العسكريه الى جيش يستخدم اسلحه غربيه
متقدمه لكن المرحله المقبله من هذه الحرب
ستكون حول الدبابات لان الدبابات القتال
الغربيه المدعومه والمدرعه ستمنح القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه مزيدا من الحركه على
الارض والحمايه من الهجوم الروسي الذي
تتوقعك في المستقبل القريب وتساعد قوه
اكياس على السعاده طبعا بعض الاراضي التي
سقطت في روسيا في المرحله الماضيه كما اكد
قائد عسكري اوكراني خط التماس مشاهدينا
بين الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي في المنطقه
الجنوبيه يشهد جمودا منذ اكثر من شهر ولم
تحدث اي اشتباكات كبيره هناك بخلاف طبعا
من طاقتي خرسان في الجنوب ودنياسك في
الشرق كما هو معلوم ومن الشرق مركز
الاشتباكات الحاليه
[موسيقى]